how could you be productive have a
vibrant life
be successful if someone else controls
all your time i find if i don't get
enough sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
that way what are you really focusing on
so
um you know i'm focusing on
those things that i think make amazon
unusual
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
i believe a life
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn how billionaires think
and get some success advice
from the top
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one manage your time well with
elon musk
you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough sleep is really
great
uh because because if i find if i don't
get enough sleep then i'm i'm
quite grumpy um i mean obviously i think
most people are that way
um and and and also um like i try to
sort of figure out what's the
right amount of sleep because like i
found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
i would get less done because
my mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours
on average per night um that's not too
bad
yeah right and any other tips on average
though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously
i mean do you do you find i mean i know
you're up here monday tuesday
is it all tesla when you're up in
silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email
during interstitial periods like you're
in a car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake
and and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone um and then
uh and then just you have to
apply a lot of hours to actual working
actually working so
the way i generally do it is i'll be
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area
spent tuesday and wednesday at the
barrier
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night
spent thursday and friday at spacex
in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex
lesson number two find your crazy idea
with larry ellison
today oracle employs around 150
000 people but when i started
it was not my intention to build a big
company
what happened well at first we did
exactly what we set out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley
we assembled an all-star team of gifted
programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company i call it
a crazy idea
because at the time everyone told me it
was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published
and ibm was building a prototype in
their research labs
but back then the collective wisdom of
computer experts
was that while relational databases
could be
built they would never be fast enough to
be useful
i thought all those so-called
computer experts were wrong
and when you start telling people that
all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates when people
start telling you
that you're crazy you just might be on
to the most
important innovation in your life lesson
number three put yourself
first with jesse itzler we live in a
world where we almost lose control of
all of our time
every day we have arrows that i call
them arrows that come at us hey
jesse can you spend 15 minutes with this
guy he wants to pick your brain on
coconut water and hey can you pay this
guy this guy wants to borrow fifty
dollars and this email needs to be
like constantly dodging all this stuff
and we feel obligated to say yes because
we don't wanna feel
you know let anyone down and we lose
control of our time
how could you be productive have a
vibrant life be successful
if someone else controls all your time
or you're filled with clutter so i did a
very simple thing
we can all do it i drew a pie chart okay
i said there's 24 hours in the day i
sleep seven of them
that leaves 17 hours in the day i take
three of them for me and those three
hours could do anything that i want i
could be i'm going for a run
a steam i'm doing nothing i'm doing my
emails i'm reading
but i don't want to resent my wife i
don't want to resent my boss
i don't resent my partner for taking
away the things in my life
that i love to do by controlling my time
three hours for me the average american
works a 40 hour work week that's eight
hours a day
seven for sleep three for yourself eight
for work guess what
you got six hours left in the day all
the clutter's gone
now of course you have to commute you
have dinner you have family you have
meals
the point is you can be incredibly
productive incredibly creative and
credibly free
when you take control of your time when
you figure out how you want to attack
your time over the course of a week
lesson number four
learn to dominate with grant cardone if
you want to be in business for yourself
and free you must learn to dominate
you cannot compete okay how many were
trained this
competition is a healthy thing that
message was not being delivered to
entrepreneurs
that message was being delivered to
consumers
there was somebody saying look the more
more oil companies we have the better
because it's good for the customer
right the the more technology companies
we have it's not just microsoft
the better for the customer and
interview inventions
and you know improvements and products
comes from competition
but if you're the one playing the game
you want to dominate the field here's
the deal i might be wrong in what i say
okay i might be wrong in the things i do
in my life and the business that i
started my family's told me not to start
every business that i've been involved
in
every one of them every one of them was
a risk every one of them i had to
take a chance i remember my mom used to
tell me i wouldn't do that if i were you
i wouldn't do that if i were you i
wouldn't do that if i were you i'm like
mommy
you wouldn't do anything well you
wouldn't do anything except
be the mother a great mother to five
children
my mother wasn't an entrepreneur she
didn't have my dreams just because she's
my mom doesn't mean she dreams like me
would you agree
okay my mom was wrong about everything
she told me not to do
love my mom to death okay unbelievable
friend of mine she was wrong
i needed to do those things okay steve
jobs needed to build this phone
would you agree did he help a lot of
people did he make some money while he
was doing it
119 billion dollars in five years
in the bank cash i'm not talking about
price
i'm talking about in the in done in the
bank sitting there okay
brings a great product to the
marketplace domination or competition
total domination coca-cola competition
or domination
total domination okay exxon total
domination
you see what i'm saying you want to be
in a dominating point okay so what we
got to do is we got to get you thinking
we got to get you thinking like
the dominators think how do they act how
does warren buffett act what does warren
buffett do with his time all the time
those are the people i study today i
don't study the people that i went to
school with
the teachers i went to school with i
don't even study my own family members
okay i'm looking for people that are way
up here that i can say
hey what are they doing because they're
doing it right hey man how you doing
buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five focus
on customer obsession with jeff bezos
there's your completely massive and
globally dominant commerce business
first party and
third party there is aws amazon web
services which came out of nowhere and
is now massive
you're in the hardware business
including echo and kindle and and the
phone
grocery delivery payments tv shows
you're now making tv shows
advertising jeff how can you possibly do
all of that exhausting me how can you
possibly do all of that
and do it okay even okay let alone good
so i think one way to think about this
is what are you really focusing on so
um you know i'm focusing on
those things that i think make amazon
unusual
uh genuine customer obsession
so like every single thing you just
mentioned when
you know when our senior executives sit
down and review those
programs they're looking for customer
obsession
lesson number six give back with bill
gates
i decided to to focus more on uh
giving away than than making money
and so i've uh gotten a chance to
travel the world be out in africa and
asia quite a bit and see the needs that
are out there
and now our foundation is very focused
on global health
uh focused on agriculture because the
majority of the the very poor in the
world are farmers who have
very small plots of land so any increase
in productivity or
certainty of their crop coming in can
make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to people who can
afford personal computers and now
uh the career at the foundation is being
very different and certainly they're
different in the sense that now it's
about vaccines now a lot it's it's with
various
uh governments uh the donor governments
the governments and
import countries but at its core it's
really
basically the same thing which is
finding innovators people who've got
breakthrough ideas
be willing to back them understand what
they're working on
measure what they're coming up with try
and make sure that when it's delivered
it really has the impact it's supposed
to be in getting into a feedback loop
driven by
a very precise measurement and lesson
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is pay attention to history with mark
cuban
when you have a good idea right you ask
your friends you ask for feedback around
you say oh i'm all excited it's a great
idea right my friends like it i can't
find
what do you do next you go to google
right and you put it in there and you
say
it's this this this you find 50
different keyword searches
and you say there's nothing there right
wow there must be it must be a great
idea no one else is doing it
wrong the reason there's nothing there
is the 15 people who did it before you
are out of business their web servers
are down and they're not indexed anymore
and there's no sense of history and a
lot of the things that are happening
you know because and particularly with
mobile apps because
there's no real web there there's like a
one-page website up that directs you to
the mobile app
there's nothing indexing the app and so
a lot of 50 different people are doing
the same app and
you know and because you can't get a url
it's
you know the xx app right and it's xxx
app
and it's hard to find the comparables
and it's hard to learn from the history
of it
and so it's whether it's google whether
it's facebook
the real challenge right now in starting
a company is you can't learn from
history because all the history is gone
and that's all at least to have that
maybe it holds us back and maybe you
know
it's the worst thing that can happen is
you know being you know ignorant of what
happened
might you know is probably better in a
lot of cases and but sometimes it's not
and so um i think that's one of the
biggest challenges that entrepreneurs
face today
that there's no history to to really go
back to look at
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an action plan for what
you're going to do
you increase it from 35 percent to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you i want to
know your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week put it down in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you it's really
important to
differentiate yourself i say that more
than anything you've got to get to the
point and you've got to
give the what's in it for them very
concisely and very quickly so
with with differentiating yourself i'll
use an example
i always say you've got to differentiate
you've got to tell the person or the
world
why you're unique and why you're
different very clearly and concisely
then you have to let them know why
you're unique and different in
comparison to
other options they may have and then you
need to let them know why that matters
to them
so i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example i also say it's really
important to sell the problem you're
solving
not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug in this
equation and how important it was the
first thing i said to the buyer or
anybody if i was in the media if i got a
chance to be on the news i would say
do you have you know you know how women
have things hanging in their closet that
we have no idea what to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say
and then you know how our underground
options they're not that great you have
regular underwear that leaves a panty
line that you can see or these very
thick heavy duty girdles that are too
thick under your beautiful clothes or
your nice slacks
and leave lines on your legs okay then
i've just given them the options that
are dysfunctional
and then i tell them well i've just
invented this product and look what it
does
it meets in the middle of the options
that are out there and here's why it's
going to be important to you here's why
it's going to matter
you're going to be able to wear white
you're going to be able to wear cream
you're finally going to be able to wear
all the
fabrics in your closet that you don't
wear anymore and you're going to
you're going to look amazing you're
going to have no lines so then i would
give the what's in it for them but
that's just a quick example and i would
always
i like to start with the problem that
i'm solving have them just sort of
invest in it with you and then um
why the other options aren't so great
people need to know
from you you're the only one that can do
it why you're their best choice
don't don't assume that they're going to
just try to figure it out people are
busy people are
you know we got a lot on our mind tell
me even in an interview when i'm
interviewing people i want them to say
i'm your best candidate and here's why
and be very clear about it
[Music]
if you want another awesome video on how
billionaires think check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there we don't love
this product but we think others will
love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either
your relationship with time is such a
key component
of your life because